we for this series and we did it but
please yes and then we decided well it
will be more concise so the numbers will
be a little easier to work with if we do
it yearly be bad what everything happens
on a month-to-month basis right but all
of the important mathematical medicine
that's why we shifted to this kind of
attention so I said let's build it from
scratch ok now I think we can notice
quite quickly now that you're somewhat
familiar with the situation ok so then
we started with a capital of a thousand
dollars and when a year lapses it gets
12 months worth of interest and we did
the calculation how much interested to
get per month 12 set so there's my 1%
and then I do it 12 times ok then the
other thing that happened was they add
it on one payment and we got that 1200
figure from 12 times one of the other
thing it was great why do you fantastic
another year passes ok now having set
this up the way we had it's not that
hard that original principal right
that's good again another 12 lots of
interests this deposit we put in after
year gets one lot of interest well sorry
one lock drive lots of interest and then
you have your final most recent lot of
fun and dollars ok great one more ok now
we can ask that we generalize i'm going
to have 36 lots of interests that 124 on
this one
12 on this one and bomb ass okay great
so at this point this is where you want
to form your series and make it nice and
obvious so you factor out or distract
her out 100 so you write your 1200 up in
front and then you place it in whatever
order is most convenient to you so it
would sort of make sense for us to start
here and then go across so you're going
to have one then you're going to have 12
then you're going to have 24 okay now
can you settle for yourself now what the
answer is for that last index we were
getting too why of em ok so the easy
parts are at the front we've already
established that that's going to be 12 m
that's fine ok then you got your 1,200
here all of your extra deposit your
first terms are all the same and then
you get onto the last term ok how do we
do it I'll try and think about in terms
of years because that's the way that's
what our M means now ok so what is 24 24
is two years worth of 12 months two
years worth of 12 months so that two
came from one less than that one less
than that one less than that that's n
minus 1 but of course you're getting 12
months of interest every single one of
those years so you should multiply that
by twelve that's why the last what they
will be critical so that will be then
and then you can do what you need to to
that to perform your arm your summer GP
and you're fine ok but let's just make
one more note i'm part of what makes
this tricky is the 12 business people
are saying to me is it n minus 12 is it
n on 12 is it plus one who who knows
right that's confusing so let's do
something earlier on to make things
easier for ourselves now I'm going to
pull this trick from a very first HSE
question I made you do yesterday which
is that you take this guy here right do
you notice that the way we've set it up
you've never ever ever get a single
interest it's always in lots of 12 okay
so you might as well consider bugs of 12
as your basic unit okay because they'll
never come in isolation so you can say
something like I think yesterday the
letter they used tubes alpha so you can
say let alpha equal to your 12 lots of
interest right 1 point 0 1 to the power
of 12 okay now this would look so much
easier for us you go again y 1 what's it
going to be a thousand alpha plus twelve
hundred you stop thinking about what
that actually is and you just realize
it's whatever interest I needed okay and
it's a lot easier to write next one a
thousand alpha squared because it just
gets another one right this one will get
now for on it then you do it again by
the time you get to why three if I skip
straight to this line what does it look
like it's 1000 now what is that if I
take out the 12 right that's 12 times 3
so that's how far cute that makes sense
okay plus and now let's do the
feminization it's 1 plus alpha plus
alpha square oh that's not so bad okay
here's it and it's really easy to
general you're almost not even the
opening when you generalize you're like
well that number matches are there and
then this number is just first sure the
same and one less worrying about 12 sore
yeah yeah thank you thank you into
Friday okay anyway sir ah that's a lying
piece of Sanders honey school anyway so
there you go I'm um I'm done you can see
that so much of what miss easy is number
one what you choose to phrase like the
whole series in clams off right and
number two just just how you write this
stuff right you can make it easier for
yourself or you could make it I mean
it's doable but let's face it you do get
confused and you
Russian media and so on ok so do
something like this be thoughtful about
it often they'll be nice and they'll
give it to you that's what that first
hoc question did but other times if we
are to you did anyone do that by the way
it did anyone bit think yeah okay good
to a cup of you now that you've seen it
do more often okay it's a really useful
thing just to make the GP really really
obvious right because you can read off
this first term one ratio alpha how many
terms and terms because this is in fact
the definition of a GP within terms it
ends on a R to the N minus 1 that's the
definition right so there you go just do
whatever you need to to make it is if
you work ok